Well hello there, SCP Fans! Let’s get
this out of the way first - You’ve
seen the title and thumbnail, and
you’re probably wondering: Wait,
is Siren Head an SCP? And the answer
is No. Siren Head is not an SCP,
it’s a freaky internet monster created by
renowned Canadian Horror Artist Trevor Henderson.
Your next question is probably: What’s with
this crazy-looking server bank behind me?
Allow me to introduce you to the Anom-O-Tron 6000,
the latest advancement of supercomputing owned and
operated exclusively by the SCP Foundation.
It’s capable of a whole bunch of interesting
features - calculating ideal containment methods,
running state of the art Foundation webcrawler
software, making and editing fun SCP YouTube
videos - but the most interesting feature that the
Anom-O-Tron has to offer is running hyper-advanced
simulations regarding all things anomalous,
with data fed into it by thousands of real-life
experiments conducted by the SCP Foundation.
It’s going to save countless dollars
and lives for Foundation researchers,
but way more importantly, it’s going
to let us explore all kinds of weird
and wacky What If scenarios that would never
happen organically. Could SCP-343 beat Goku,
or Superman? Who’s a deadlier supernatural killer,
SCP-106 or Freddy Kreuger? Would the world simply
explode from adorableness if SCP-999 and Baby Yoda
ever crossed those multiversal barriers and met?
We can explore all of these questions -
Along with any others you may have down
in the comments. Seriously, comment it.
We dare you! - but to get things started,
we figured we’d make the Anom-O-Tron pit
the Foundation’s lankiest nightmare monster,
SCP-096, against the internet’s
- Trevor Henderson’s Siren Head.
Sorry, Slender Man, you’re just not cool anymore.
So, without further adieu, let’s
kick the Anom-O-Tron into gear and
see how this wild battle plays out.
It’s time for SCP-096 Vs Siren Head!
Ricky and Eliot, a pair of aspiring
travel YouTubers from California,
were taking a vacation to the Pacific Northwest
to spend some time in the area’s beautiful,
lush forests. However, while the duo were
both big fans of travel for its own sake,
they weren’t just here for the trees and fresh
air. You see, despite their jetsetting lifestyle,
Ricky and Eliot’s subscribers and views hadn’t
exactly been phenomenal lately. Turns out,
hiking vlogs and GoPro footage of the two
of them jumping into absurdly blue water in
Bali weren’t exactly that interesting
to people who weren’t actually there.
But Ricky had formulated an ingenious
plan to pull the two of them out of
obscurity. They would hunt down and film
real footage of the legendary Siren Head,
a supernatural monster said to haunt forests and
isolated graveyards. There were plenty of fakers
out there on YouTube, but if the two of them
could get real footage of Siren Head - and also,
preferably, survive the experience - they’d be
framing their Golden Play Buttons in no time.
But they were already encountering
certain issues. For starters,
the two Californians had severely underestimated
just how cold it was in the Pacific Northwest,
and as such, were already shivering from
bone-deep cold. The second issue was food:
While the two of them had thought ahead and
brought a selection of tasty protein bars,
they’d also gotten hungry during the early
hours of their walk, and eaten all of them,
leaving them feeling severely out of
luck by the time dinner rolled around.
And the third and perhaps most problematic
issue of all was the fact that Ricky and
Eliot didn’t exactly have a great sense of
direction. During all of their previous trips,
they’d been on guided tours with
local experts. In this instance,
wanting to take all the Siren Head glory and clout
for themselves, they’d decided to come in alone,
with the incredibly janky Google
Maps app to guide them. As such,
as the night was creeping in, the two aspiring
YouTube celebrities had no idea where they were.
Needless to say, it wasn’t
exactly an ideal situation.
And to make matters worse, Ricky and Eliot
had been experiencing some strange feelings
for the last couple of hours, when they’d
gotten particularly deep into the forest.
That dread-inducing sensation of being watched
by something lurking just out of sight. A gaze
with some unknowable and darkly malicious
intent boiling behind it. These two poor
saps had no idea what was in store for
them tonight, and wouldn’t you know it,
the one watching them right now wouldn’t
even be the only monster after them.
After an expectable amount of bumbling and
buffoonery, Ricky and Eliot managed to gather up
enough tinder to make a semi-respectable campfire.
They could sleep out here tonight, then set off in
search of Siren Head or civilization - whichever
came first - in the daylight the next day. The
duo did what they could to remain chipper, in
spite of the ominous circumstances. Sure, they
were trapped in the depths of the woods, alone,
but think of the amazing vlog footage they’d get!
They’d be like the next Blair Witch
crew, except they’d live, hopefully!
But as the duo sat next to their campfire, they
felt that ominous sensation again. The hairs
on the back of their necks started standing
up. They felt shivers that didn’t just come
from the cold. More and more, they started to
feel certain that something in this forest was
watching them. Something ancient and powerful
and evil. That’s when one of them heard the
telltale crackle of radio static, and their
skeletons almost jumped out of their skin.
Could it be him? The Patron Saint
of Going Missing Without a Trace,
of Creeping Dread, of Bad Things
Coming? Siren Head himself?
Both men fell silent. All they could hear was
the crackling of their own fire. Had the sound
before just been an illusion? A product of
a pair of paranoid minds also predisposed
to sense Siren-Headed monsters lurking amongst
the trees? They’d been reading about a higher
rate of disappearances in this area, along with
a number of frightening sightings of tall, thin
beings and radio static that seemed perfectly
consistent with Siren Head activity. That’s
why they’d come here in the first place.
But had they come here to their deaths?
The two needed to distract themselves or they’d
go mad from the paranoia. They decided to share
a few fun little anecdotes of the travels
they’d had before meeting one another, showing
the photos they’d saved on their smartphones.
Ricky had been to Hawaii, Tahiti, Bora Bora,
Fiji, St. Lucia, and the Maldives. Clearly,
he liked his vacations warm and sandy. Eliot,
on the other hand, tended to like his trips to be
a little more adventurous. He’d seen volcanoes,
waterfalls, deep and treacherous cave systems,
and of course, a little guided mountaineering.
One photo that Eliot showed Ricky
was particularly breathtaking:
He was standing in the foreground of a snowy
landscape, with an incredible mountain range
behind him. When Ricky asked Eliot where exactly
he’d taken this picture, strangely enough,
he drew a complete blank. Maybe somewhere
in Canada, or Siberia, or something like
that… But it was a hell of a trip, whatever
the case, he remembered having a great time.
It was such a tiny detail, but when looking at the
photo, Ricky couldn’t help but notice something
in the background. A speck of white. Sure, not
exactly newsworthy in a snowy mountain range,
but this wasn’t snow. It was a
speck of white that seemed to
be a slightly different shade than the
rest of the mountain. Strange. Perhaps
it was just some tiny particle stuck on
the lens whenever the photo was taken.
The two continued to chat and
warm their hands against the fire,
having no idea of the horror
they’d just awoken in doing so.
Over a hundred miles away, at an
SCP Foundation containment site,
researchers and guards walked around the
perimeter of a huge, airtight metal cube,
reading off diagnostics and audio recordings.
For reasons that should be obvious to everyone
who’s a fan of this channel, there
were no camera feeds coming from the
inside of the great metal cube. Only a faint
whimpering sound, like a sad, wounded animal,
and the clanking of pacing feet moving back and
forth over the metal, dragging forlorn knuckles.
It turned every head in the room when
the crying started to get louder. Soon,
it wasn’t just quiet weeping, it was a
series of horrendous, slobbering sobs,
wails of pure pain and despair. Someone in
the room screamed “Close your eyes and hit
the deck!”, knowing exactly what had happened.
They’d learned well enough from the infamous
Incident 096-1-A Containment Breach that there
was no way of stopping this thing until it’d
run its course. The best they could do was
minimize their own fatalities in the process.
Everyone in the room did as they were told,
hitting the ground, closing their eyes,
and covering them with their hands, just
to be safe. That’s when the solid steel
of the cube was torn open like crepe paper,
and the howling, raging SCP-096 broke free,
galloping on all fours through the nearest wall,
shattering it and spraying debris everywhere.
As Mobile Task Forces were dispatched to track
the rampaging abomination and try their best to
clear the path ahead as it sought out its
target, one thought was going through the
minds of everyone in the room: “Woe betide
the poor fools who saw that monster’s face…”
Back in the deep, dark forests of the Pacific
Northwest, the presence of some unnerving force
was becoming far harder to deny for Ricky and
Eliot. They heard the sounds of garbled voices out
in the woods. The squeals and crackles of radio
static. They saw shapes moving amongst the trees,
tall and thin, like long, spindly limbs.
While neither wanted to voice their fear,
they were both thinking similar things:
If there really was a monster out here,
why hadn’t it killed them? It had
all the time in the world to do it.
But that was just it, wasn’t it? It had all
the time in the world, so why rush? It had
every advantage. It could take its time, and do
this exactly how it wanted to. Ricky and Eliot
had made themselves the perfect prey. And
as they saw a huge, lithe figure suddenly
separate itself from the trees, they began
to wonder if it was really worth it to risk
both of their lives for YouTube clout. Either
way, it was now probably too late for regrets.
Ricky and Eliot’s jaws fell in horror as the
monster emerged from the darkness before them.
They recognized the awful, mottled skin
stretched over the monster’s forty-foot
frame. They saw the grasping hands, and
up above, the nightmarish, faceless head,
split into a pair of sirens pointing in different
directions, each one filled with gnashing
teeth and slithering tongues. It was even more
terrifying than they possibly could have imagined.
Siren Head’s speakers crackled into life,
and hissed out, “NINE. EIGHTEEN.
ONE. CHILD. SEVENTEEN. REMOVE. VILE.”
Ricky and Eliot stumbled
backwards as Siren Head advanced,
its speakers still bleeding hateful
static. Neither could move or speak,
only watch as its long, gnarled fingers
reached from the dark to grasp them.
There was a terrible pained wail in the woods
after that. But it wasn’t coming from Ricky,
Eliot, or Siren Head. It was distant at first,
but soon became louder and louder as the force’s
point of origin came barreling towards them.
Even Siren Head couldn’t help but turn to
see SCP-096, a flash of terrible white fury,
come charging towards them in the dark,
knowing down all the trees in its path.
Leaves and pine needles scattered. Trunks
exploded into splinters. Nothing would stop
the Shy Guy from claiming its prey. Nothing
would stop it from destroying Ricky, and now,
as it approached, Eliot made the fatal
mistake of looking at its face, too.
096 lunged, ready to go in for the kill,
when Siren Head’s hands closed around the
Shy Guy’s slender torso. In one fluid motion,
with surprising strength for its scrawny build,
it hurled the Shy Guy into the distance,
smashing another several trees in its path.
The words, “MY PREY. MY PREY. MINE. MINE. MINE,”
hissed out of its speakers.
But 096 was only down for mere moments. It
sprung back up on its hind and forelegs and
started galloping towards Ricky and Eliot again,
who were still frozen in place. This time,
just before the Shy Guy’s terrible claws could
close around the two hapless wannabe YouTubers,
down came Siren Head’s clenched fist,
pounding 096’s head into the dirt.
Overhead, Mobile Task Force helicopters
circled, wearing their SCRAMBLE goggles
and trying to get a visual on the situation
unfolding below. They could hardly believe what
they were seeing down there. Was some other
unclassified anomaly managing to intercept
SCP-096 in its rage state? Only a handful of
anomalies on record had ever been shown as
being capable of such a feat. It seemed they
were dealing with something serious here.
Down below, the battle continued. Siren
Head had a unique advantage over most
other combatants facing SCP-096: It was
an extradimensional being with no eyes,
merely an innate psychic awareness of its
victims around it - not unlike how SCP-096
detects people seeing its face in photographs
or videos without need for any kind of direct
contact. As such, it was impossible for
Siren Head to see the Shy Guy’s face,
and thus, impossible for the Shy Guy to ever
actually direct its aggression against it.
Whether or not 096 would kill-steal Siren Head’s
intended prey was another matter entirely.
In the night’s first minor miracle, Ricky
and Eliot remembered that they’d been born
with working legs, and decided that right now
would be an excellent time to use them. They
turned and began to run while Siren Head continued
beating the Shy Guy into the dirt, sprinting with
all their might. However, the growing distance
between them only aggravated the Shy Guy further.
It sprang out from the dirt with unstoppable
force and broke away from Siren Head’s grip.
The Shy Guy never wasted time, ever, it always
made a beeline for its intended victim with
one directive in mind: Total annihilation.
Tonight is no different. Ricky and Eliot
screamed as they heard its pounding
gallop on the ground behind them.
Closer, closer, closer…
Then suddenly, defying all spatial reasoning,
Siren Head emerged out of the darkness between
Ricky, Eliot, and 096. Being forty feet tall,
Siren Head dwarfed even the Shy Guy. It lunged
and grabbed the wailing white monstrosity,
holding it as one would a particulary vicious
cat and trying to keep it in place. Siren
Head wanted to crush this monster’s bones and
carry on stalking its feeble human prey - who
were currently in the process of getting
away - but somehow, that was impossible.
It was almost like the monster
had an indestructible skeleton…
Up above, the Mobile Task Forces continued
observing this clash of the titans from their
two helicopters. Seeing how Siren Head was somehow
doing a serviceable job of subduing the Shy Guy,
one of the task force members joked,
“Maybe we should hire this guy.”
Another chimed in, “I don’t think we
have any ballistic vests in his size.”
The laughter soon turned to screams when Siren
Head hurled SCP-096’s flailing body up at one
of the helicopters with incredible force, knocking
it out of the sky. It careened down to the ground,
a ball of fear and violence, before
exploding. Anyone who survived the
initial blast was unlucky enough to have seen
the Shy Guy’s face. Their screams rang out,
briefly, before being abruptly silenced by the
monster. Helicopter Alpha had no survivors.
Meanwhile, Ricky and Eliot had kept running
until their lungs burned and their muscles
pumped thumbtacks. Seeing that the chaos was so
far behind them now, they took a moment to stop
and breathe, recomposing themselves. In the second
minor miracle of the night, it looked like the two
of them had actually survived this ordeal. Those
two horrific monsters had canceled each other out.
But Ricky and Eliot were about to learn a
harsh lesson: They really weren’t that lucky.
The last thing the two ever saw
was Siren Head emerging from the
darkness once more. The last thing they
ever felt was the monster’s terrible,
gnarled fingers curling around their bodies,
too fast for them to escape. And the last thing
they ever heard was each other’s screams,
followed by a sickeningly meaty crunch.
Elsewhere in the forest, SCP-096’s
wails died down to its usual maudlin
sob. The rage state had ended; all
of its targets had been destroyed.
It just hadn’t been the one to
do all of the destroying, per se.
Not long after that, Helicopter Bravo descended
safely and the remaining MTF members closed around
the blubbering beast. Someone black bagged
it and everyone breathed a sigh of relief,
knowing that was at least one
monster taken care of tonight.
“What about the other one?”
the MTF Lieutenant asked.
The team’s commander shook his head and
said, “Let’s worry about that freak later
and get 096 back to containment.
This place gives me the creeps…”
Now go check out “SCP-096 - Look at
a Picture of Shy Guy in Space? The
Shy Guy Questions and Theories” and
“SCP-096 Shy Guy ESCAPE - Incident
096-1-A Containment Breach” for more wild
tales of the world’s scariest introvert!